Now we will look at two possible
optimizations of a write-update
protocol.
The first optimization we'll look
at is about avoiding memory writes.
Remember that in a write-update
protocol, every write in any of
the processors,needs to be broadcast on
the BUS and needs to update the memory.
Because memory is big and slow, it
cannot keep up with all the writes, and
that means that the memory throughput
becomes a bottleneck for the system.
Pretty much it's not about how
much traffic can the BUS take,
it's about how much traffic
can the memory take.
So we want to avoid
unnecessary memory writes.
These caches previously behaved
as write-through caches.
Every write was going
through the cache to memory.
And we have seen already that
write-through is bad for
memory traffic even with a single core.
Now we are adding more than one core, so
it's going to be even a bigger problem.
So the solution to reducing memory
traffic here will be the same.
We will add a dirty bit to each
block in each of the caches, and
this dirty bit will allow
us to delay a memory write
until we actually replace
a dirty block from our cache.
So now let us see how this work and
how it avoids memory writes.
Suppose that this cache reads A.
It gets this value from memory,
let's say it's 6.
The tag will be A.
It's valid and it's not dirty.
Now this cache writes A.
At this point, it will broadcast
the write with the address of A and
the value that it writes, let's say 17.
So this cache here
would update the value.
Now without the dirty bit, the memory
would also be updated with A = 17.
We want to avoid that.
Why?
Well,
because there could be
a lot of writes here
until we finally replace
it in a write by cache.
So what we will do is we will write 17,
tag it this way, and mark this as dirty.
Dirty means two things here.
One is that the memory is not up
to date and we need to update it.
This is exactly the same as in a normal
uniprocessor write-back cache.
If we replace something dirty,
we have to send it right back to memory.
In our write-update protocol,
dirty has another meaning
that we will now illustrate.
Suppose that this cache replaces this
block and then wants to read it again.
So it issues a request
to read on the BUS.
And now normally the memory
would respond with a value, but
the memory still has
the old value of A = 6.
This cache here has
the only up-to-date copy.
That's what the dirty
bit also stands for.
So now this cache needs
to snoop reads as well.
Notice that we are reading the same
block that it has in a dirty state.
So instead of the memory being
allowed to respond, we respond first.
The cache is faster than the memory,
so it will respond quicker, and
say that A is 17.
So now here we get A becomes 17
in this cache and it's not dirty.
Now after this, let's say that we write
a new value here of let's say 20.
We put the new value here.
We broadcast the new value on the BUS.
The snooping here gets that 20, but
the memory again doesn't get updated.
If this block, however,
gets replace from this cache,
then an update is sent to memory.
Another interesting situation here is
what happens if we have the block dirty
in this cache, and
now this cache writes 30 to A.
In that case,
this cache broadcasts the write.
This cache snoops the right,
puts 30 in its cache.
Now this cache is no
longer responsible for
writing back to memory, because the new
writer takes that responsibility and
the memory still doesn't get updated.
So as you can see, we can now do many
writes without updating the memory.
We can even move the responsibility for
updating memory to another cache and
keep writing there,
without the updates to memory.
Only when the last writer replaces
the block that is still dirty
will we have a single write to memory.
So the benefits of having
the dirty bit are that
we can now write to the memory
only when the block is replaced.
So we can do many writes
without updating the memory,
thus saving a lot of
the writes to memory.
And also we avoid memory reads
because now we allow reads from memory
only when nobody has
the block in a dirty state.
If the block is dirty, for example here,
then whoever asks for this block, this
is the cache that will provide the value
and the memory doesn't need to do that.
So we are also saving reads
from memory this way.